(clapping)
- Last month marked the 20th anniversary
of your debut album, which is crazy!
- Yeah that is crazy.
(cheering)
- I mean that's amazing.
I literally remember when you came out
and I was like finally!
(laughing)
I was like our generation
has this big, bold vocalist.
Because we grew up with
so many great vocalists
like listen to it.
- We did, and the ballad era.
- Oh my god, the 1990s were so good.
I miss the 1990's.
- Oh, nostalgic.
- Oh, I know.
But I was so excited, can
you believe it though?
20 years.
- I definitely look back at old pictures
and now that it's the 20th anniversary,
and I'm just like aww cute.
Like, it's baby Christina.
(laughing)
- Yeah!
- But now I feel like I,
could like, mother her now.
I'm like it's okay, like we're gonna,
you know what I mean?
Cause when you get older
you're just so much more
self-assured and it's like,
I wouldn't pay to go back to the 20's.
- Becoming a mother helped me with that.
(laughing)
All my 20's sucked.
- But it was fun, kind of along the way.
But I could do without a
lot of the insecurities
that you shed and would
know when you get older.
But, yeah.
- And also, everybody thinks
it's success, success,
like oh you must be the
happiest person ever.
- [Christina] Oh it's so much hard work.
And honestly those were
like my darkest moments
cause your so busy and your just so damn.
- We are twins, we're separated at birth.
- I know I've heard you
in interviews and I'm like
I know.
(laughing)
- I'm like, no I get it
it can be really hard
and people think your like
the greatest thing ever,
and it's like, I'm so tired.
(laughing)
And your voice is wrecked
and people expect,
and you don't learn how to say no.
- Yes.
- You don't learn how to say no.
- You're absolutely right.
- And your in your 30's
and you're like no.
(laughing)
- Yes we have the right to say no
and that is something that,
you know, they don't teach you.
Especially as young girls
coming up in the business too.
It's a very male dominated
industry and I always had
older managers and things,
and agendas and a schedule.
Since I was seven. It's hard
to look at my kids and be like.
- Seven?
- Yeah, I love it. I was born to do it,
I can't think of anything else. But, yeah.
- That's crazy!
- I mean people, they
look at how it looks on tv
and all the glamor and things like that
but the inner workings and the
behind the scenes of it all,
it's brutal and you do have to have.
- [Kelly] Thick skin.
- [Kelly] And learn to have a thick skin.
Learn to say no, like you said.
And be there for yourself.
- And surround yourself
with people that love you
and don't want to just
ride your coat tails
and make money off of you.
- It's true.
And it's important.
(clapping)
Absolutely.
I've always been a diary
girl, I don't know about you.
- Me too.
- I'm a scrapbooker, a diary
girl, so I like, I literally.
- I'm a scrapbooker!
(laughing)
- But it's so interesting. I
was looking back at old diaries
and I was like, oh my
god some of me has like
not changed at all.
I think it's really
important to stay grounded
and have that connection with yourself
and who you are and where you came from.
- And not forget where you came from.
- And we have real
backgrounds and histories.
- Yeah, yeah.
- We weren't raised with silver spoons.
- No.
(laughing)
- No offense to anyone
that has, good for you.
- No, great for you.
Our kids are going to be like
that, that's what's so funny.
My kids are going to
never know what it's like
to go without.
- It's crazy.
- So that's just beautiful.
- And my son is sometimes
like, your house is too big.
I'm like uh.
(laughing)
- My house is too big?
- I got mad at my kids
once because I was like.
- They like cozy.
- Are you sad in your mansion?
(laughing)
- I was like are you sad?
Was your unicorn not glittery enough?
- That's right. Mummy
worked hard for this,
Yeah, exactly.
- I was like, I'm working hard.
- Yeah, I know, I know.
- I mean we gotta whip them into shape.
But another thing I love
about you that's coming out,
and I'm very excited for this, is,
you have a huge Halloween project
that you're part of right?
- I do.
- [Kelly] Okay, tell us.
- I'm a tremendous fan
of The Addams Family
And it's a Halloween project.
(cheering)
And they're coming out
with an animated film
so I am so there.
I haven't seen it yet so I'm very excited
and I'm singing one of
the title songs off of it
called Haunted Heart and it's really cool.
(cheering)
- I'm in, it says haunted.
(laughing)
- Yeah, super cool and
I love Halloween too.
Like, it's right up there with Christmas.
I love dressing up the kids.
I literally have walk
through haunted houses,
that I do.
- [Kelly] Oh I don't do that.
- For the neighborhood.
(laughing)
- See I get into it.
- The last time I went in a haunted house
I was throwing women and
children out of the way.
(laughing)
To get out. I don't like to be scared.
I married the wrong person,
he loves to scare the
crap out of everyone.
(laughing)
- And I'm like, if you do it
there's no cuddles for you
for a week.
I hate being scared, I can't
even do haunted houses, no.
- You can pick your level though.
You can go okay I want a level one.
- Okay I want Candyland.
- Kids can do it.
- That's a good game, I like it.
- Actually that would be
creepy. That might be creepy.
Like scary Candyland.
We're on to something here.
- I kinda love it.
(laughing)
I think you came up with a great plan.
- I know, we're gonna do this.
But also, here's the
big news also as well,
your Vegas Residency at Planet
Hollywood was just extended.
(cheering)
Through 2020.
(clapping)
What do you love because
everybody's doing a Vegas there,
so what do you love about it?
- The experience.
You have to come.
Bring a fun group of people because I love
feeding off the energy.
- Yes.
- But it's a great environment.
It's a great place to be
expressive and creative.
I feel at home most when I'm on stage
and it's a five sensory experience.
So you can smell, taste.
- It's like that ride!
(laughing)
- You know that ride, what is it?
- Soarin' over?
- Soarin' over California!
Yes, I love that ride.
- I love it.
- And you smell like jasmine.
- Yes, yes.
- I actually, it's so funny you say, we.
- I know.
I also have a snow globe idea.
I wanna do a Christmas show in Vegas
and I want it all to be a snow globe.
(gasp)
And then create my whole world.
So we're so similar.
- Oh my god.
You should come and we
should sing a song in Vegas.
- Okay, that makes me nervous.
(cheering)
- [Christina] Yes.
- [Kelly] I would love to.
Do you have any crazy,
cause this is thing my
husband and I try to do
cause we have four kids
and it's fun to just be
like a fun adult again and
have a night with your ladies
or your friends or whatever,
and so, do you have any
wild, fun nights in Vegas?
- All the good ones I'm proud
to have minimal memory of.
(laughing)
I mean it's Vegas right?
No, I like to go out with my, like crew.
Like my dancers are so fun to go out with.
- Oh my gosh, or not because
then you feel stupid.
(laughing)
Cause you're like no you look great,
no I'm not going to join you.
- No I kinda like let them,
but they're entertaining.
They're just like.
- Yeah my band's like that.
Yeah my band's like that.
They're all cool.
- Yes your band, you know.
- I know.
(cheering)
Jacka, Jesse, all of them up there,
Yes.Yeah.
- I know I'm like woo.
- I love my band.
You probably gotta be like
that with your crew too.
But, I just wanna thank you.
I know your so busy, you're
a momma, you're working hard.
I get it.
So thank you for coming.
- You're so good!
- Thank you!
- Love it.